bonsoir jean marie bigard merci de me
recevoir
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rtl
france alors candidat ou pas candidat
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on vous
présente et donc ne les listes ont pas
publiées alors voilà les listes seront
publiées le 27 février donc ce soit bien
clair on est pour l'instant il n'y a pas
de listes ya pas de tête de liste elles
ne sont pas encore dévoilés mais moi
j'ai une amitié avec marcel campion qui
date de 30 ans je suis venu le soutenir
c'est très clair parce que c'est un il
est apolitique c'est en fait partie
d'aucun parti précisément et que j'aime
bien sa démarche et puis le petit vent
de de liberté il souffle par la bouche
d'un d'un électron libre
on va dire qu'il fait pas trop peur à
qui que ce soit on est bien d'accord
mais quand même faut voir pour voir les
gens peuvent aimer ce petit souffle de
liberté mais ce que vous avez envie d'y
aller
ah oui je suis très clairement pour le
pousser pour le pour l'encourager je
suis j'allais dire comme les millions de
parisiens et d'utilisateurs de paris je
suis exaspéré par la gestion lamentable
qui a été fait sur paris par madame
hidalgo et donc ça m'est insupportable
de voir que on peut laisser une femme
qui n'a aucune autorité pour être à ce
poste aucune légitimité puisque elle a
même perdu
battu à plate couture dans son propre
arrondissement le 15e arrondissement
elle a fait 35% et cette femme par le
jeu des lois et des règles se retrouve
sur le trône de paris donc c'est
insupportable parce que laisser une
femme faire à la prix paris quasiment à
zéro
elle a fait 6 milliards de dette c'est
pas mal quand même fou y avait 1 pour
faire faut pas chômé pour faire 6
milliards et l'idée que cette femme
puisse reproduire la même chose dans les
cinq ans qui viennent
refaire un nouveau 6 milliards elle a
précisé que les 8300 chantier ça
changerait pas ce serait toujours la
même chose pour rire la circulation dans
paris laissait cette ville qui était la
plus belle ville du monde envahi par la
saleté par les rats et tout est bien je
me dis je suis une personnalité et à
canton quand on a le bras qui va loin où
la voix qui porte
ils foutent pense qu'il faut donner son
avis à grand pouvoir grande
responsabilité
c'est dans spider man alors on va parler
de sondage à plusieurs titres puisque
sondage ifop 1 pour les municipales paru
hier chez nos confrères du journal du
dimanche qui doit pas vous faire plaisir
oui il note quand même il donne anne
hidalgo en tête en quelques jours après
sa déclaration de candidature 25 1%
marcel campion 0 5%
est ce que pour vraiment être utile il
aurait pas mieux fallu peut-être
s'engager sur un candidat qui avait
peut-être d'amendements chance d'avoir
un jour d'aujourd'hui aucun sondage qui
ne vaut quoi que ce soit un marcel très
bien libérons paris s'est plutôt bien
finir à 5 6%
on ne croit pas et à 5 6% devient
dangereux pour tout le monde donc c'est
assez rigolo de participer à cette
aventure
et puis ensuite bon ben je suis je dois
le rappeler ici à cause de la loi plm
donc la loi paris lyon marseille ce ne
sont pas ni les parisiens ni les
lyonnaises et lionel il est marseillaise
marseillais qui élisent leur mère dans
ces trois villes là ce sont les
conseillers municipaux et donc
évidemment comme eux ils sont déjà en
place elle se retrouve naturellement
favorite mais sans le peuple
alors voilà par exemple quelque chose
qui m'exaspère si au vote universel
direct par exemple on faisait un sondage
comme celui du journal du dimanche
on va dire qu'elle ferait 8% quoi est il
faut expliquer à tous les français et à
madame hidalgo particuliers que pour
être le maire de sa ville
dans toutes les autres villes de france
faut 50% plus une voix mais qu'on soit 3
8%
on les élit par arrondissement dont on
sait très bien qu'ils vont voter après
année donc c'est quand même une forme de
démocratie
ben c'est une forme avec comme on dit un
filtre c'est le peuple
on demande juste aux peuvent de fermer
sa gueule au moment de prendre la
décision
ce n'est pas du tout logique que lier
une exception pour lui trois plus
grandes villes de france
nous réclamons le vote pour notre mère
d'abord il y aurait plus de gens qui
auraient voté à paris parce que c'est
une cata la catastrophe je vais vous
dire où elle et stéphanie sait qu'il ya
deux millions deux cent quarante mille
parisien il ya seulement un million qui
ont leur carte d'électeur et sur ce
million il n'a que six cent mille qui
votent et là on peut pas y arriver
c'est à dire si les gens se disaient
c'est nous qui allons élire notre mère à
ce moment là bas ils prendraient plus
volontiers leur cas et les irène plus
volontiers faire leur devoir civique
donc c'est vers ça que je veux
encourager les gens si tu veux te
plaindre va voter c'est le seul moment
où le peuple a le pouvoir c'est pendant
le petit dixième de seconde ou le
bulletin tombe dans l'urne
alors je pose c'est fini c'est vrai
qu'ici beaucoup de parisiens qui
estiment capables beaucoup de choix
montre est satisfaisant de candidats
c'est ce qu'on entend ici ou là il ya
aussi la rivalité benjamin griveaux
cédric villani qui a eu deux font
finalement 28% au total rachida dati
quitte à kehl rachida dati qui fait nous
percée 1 19% toujours selon les sondages
vous aviez à l'époque on s'en souvient
en 2007 ça fait longtemps que la vie ait
regretté
depuis ils sont tenus nicolas sarkozy
qui était très proche de rachida dati
qui était sa garde des sceaux vous
pourriez par exemple soutenir
j'adore c'est elle qui m'a marier avec
avec ma femme de ce que tu es dans le 7e
arrondissement et elle s'est déplacé
pour venir nous nous marier donc ses
études dans la vie c'est une amie et
donc je suis très content pour elle
qu'elle fasse un très bon score qu'elles
soient pour l'instant si j'ai bien
compris en seconde position
vous pourriez la soupe on est à je peux
je pourrais oui c'est à dire quand les
jeux seront un peu plus fait quand il
faudra faire un choix si vous me
demandez si je choisis anne hidalgo ou à
rachida dati
évidemment que j'ai mille pour cent je
choisis rachida dati
les deux faisceaux c'est impossible de
faire une gestion plus mauvaise de paris
que celle de anne hidalgo qui encore une
fois n'a aucune légitimité pour occuper
ce poste
aujourd'hui votre voix est entendue nous
avait l'impression d'être écoutés avec
coup j'ai l'impression qu'on veut me
faire fermer ma gueule ce qui est plutôt
déjà une bonne chose
apparemment nous a ici pas ici merci
merci à tous pas ici mais par exemple
delphine ernotte me vire de la chaîne
publique c'est-à-dire à l'interdît on
est en 2020 on est on est en france un
vous souvenez de sa connerie gens se
rappellent bien en deçà 2020 france et l
m'interdit comme à l'époque de giscard
d'estaing où on disait giscard est
montré du doigt quelqu'un les a lui fini
puis télé c'était l'aspect de dictature
douce que notre joue un peu mais qu en
france 3 mais bon c'est l approche à
votre avis c'est la question que je me
pose c'est à dire que d'abord je suis
honoré je tiens à dire delphine ernotte
si elle m'écoute ce moment je suis
honorée et qu'elle mais censuré parce
que je rentre dans le panthéon des gens
formidables qui ont été par le passé
censuré je parle du chanteur renaud de
coluche 2
tu vois ou plus récemment de patrick
sébastien par exemple donc je suis
plutôt honoré c'est une médaille pour
moi c'est mon molière à moins d'être
censuré à la différence des autres et
critiquer ouvertement donc les gens qui
nous gouvernaient à l'époque
moi j'ai rien fait de tout ça mais jean
marie bigard tout le monde vous êtes
vous est-ce que vous acceptez que je
vous dit vous savez bien vous jouer
parfois la provocation et quelques
petits scandales sort quelques plateaux
est ce que voilà vous regrettez pas
justement finalement que ça puisse nuire
à votre image me le craignez vous pas
honte mais ça ne nuit pas à mon image
puisque les les gens qui nous gouvernent
son des maracas et donc moi je suis très
volontiers amis dit gilet jaune je les
soutiens depuis le début et sans
intermittence je suis un ami de la
police aussi donc moi je sais ma voix
est libre et c'est bon des fois de
respirer un peu de liberté donc chaque
fois qu'on me sanctionne ou comme
condamne je gagne des des followers
je gagne trois cent mille abonnés à
chaque fois donc ne pas leur en vouloir
il me renforce en fait parce que quand
on fait partie d'aucune famille ce qui
est mon cas
6les de la famille des forums avec
marcel campion et bien on a toutes les
familles contre soi à l'époque que lui
qui disait tous les partis sont menées
warm disant vous ne craignez rien de
nous mais méfiez vous des autres quand
vous dites vous êtes amis des gilets
jaunes et de la police vous savez qu'il
ya une polémique évidemment ça vous a
pas échappé aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
marine le pen et olivier faure le
socialiste demande tous deux le départ
du préfet de police de paris
cette incompréhension vous guerrier ce
malentendu on parle beaucoup de
violences policières ce manifestant
d'ailleurs qui porte plainte
les trois policiers aussi quelle est
votre réaction par un temps se dit ami
des deux voilà c'est à dire l'usure et
les nerfs
et crac de tous les côtés c'est à dire
tout le monde peut craquer il ya que nos
gouvernants qui peuvent mettre siffle la
fin du match mais il ne le siffle pas
ils s'en foutent c'est à dire le
gouvernant n'écoute pas le peuple peuple
grande est de plus en plus en colère
les policiers sont de plus en plus
dépassés ne me mets à la place des uns
et des autres et c'est absolument
logique et normale celle inverse qui
serait étonnant que la laine
évidemment comme dit un ami rappeur fait
pas de coquard sans casser des yeux et
effectivement la violence elle est
forcément lié à tout mouvement social et
la police ils en ont ras-le-bol vraiment
ils sont utilisés à 1000% et puis je
sais pas ce qu'on attend que tout le
monde craque au qu'elle soit vraiment le
chaos pour intervenir
non on a des dirigeants on a de sécurité
on a tout ce qu'il faut siffler la fin
du match mais a eu l'impression que ça
les intéresse pas de trop rapidement
parce qu'on arrive déjà à la fin de
cette interview le gouvernement aurait
clairement dû retirer cette réforme des
retraites avant que cette violence
arrivent la grève se muant via la rue
c'est à dire on sait très bien qu'il ya
une loi qui se prépare on met le la
barre ici on sait très bien qu'il faudra
reculer
donc il aurait été peut-être été plus
adroits de reculer plus vite pour
éteindre le feu quoi certainement là on
laisse bien pourrir le truc jusqu'au
jusqu'à ce que les débordements soir est
insupportable pour tout le monde
merci jean marie bigard d'avoir été
indiqué avoir reçu merci avec mon direct
donc sur arte france est donc quelques